hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen guys I'm so
excited about this whole month the next
five videos are going to be horror
themed and I love scary movies honestly
I wasn't allowed to watch scary movies
growing up and I think I started liking
them in high school because I wanted to
appear cool and cool girls watch scary
movies cuz we're tough just a load of
crap if you don't like scary movies you
could still be tough and you don't have
to do anything to impress people which
is something that I have learned later
in life took me a while today I'm
watching Evil Dead it is a cult classic
that I've never seen I've never seen any
of the Evil Dead movies or the remake or
the TV show I guess there's a TV show to
fly okay but yeah I'm super crazy
excited to watch this movie with you
guys kinda with you I'm watching alone
but you're there in spirit
thank you so let's get started Oh
cameras never seen
[Music]
towba fest
oh it was so cheesy you got it's bad in
a great fantastic way is this a comedy
is it a scary movie is it a comedic
scary movie I can't tell
it starts off and they're in this car
and the acting is horrific so they pull
up to the cabin that they're gonna be
staying in and everyone's like Oh gross
it's yucky we don't want to stay here
I'm like simmer down everyone that's
like my dream is to live in this little
cottage in like Colorado or Washington
State but then also have a private jet
that can take me to Chicago twice a week
you know simple requests also I might
have missed this why are they staying at
this cabin how do they know about this
cabin is it's not some one of their
families right oh why are they going
this place why are they going like
camping or something how did they know
so many questions I have a lot of
questions about this cabin and then out
of nowhere comes this demon voice that's
like join us and this home girl who's
like drawing a clock randomly in the
corner her hand gets possessed and then
noises start coming up from the cellar
door and then it cuts to another scene
no one addresses it no one's like
concerned well she doesn't tell anyone
she's just sitting there at dinner
eating her particular Peas and her
potatoes and like just like oh I'm sure
that was a one-time occurrence so
they're all a dinner and the cellar door
swings open and everyone's like well
well maybe we should go check this out
like the girl who was drawing should
have done when her hand was possessed
and when there were noises coming out of
it you know maybe alerted someone about
it and then the stupidest scene in the
world happens everything with this guy I
forget that character's name it'll come
up later again but like the bro
character the guy who's not Ashe is such
a terrible character and
one of the girls is like well maybe it's
an animal or something and he's like an
animal it's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard of hahahahaha she's like well
but it could maybe it is though he's
like yeah maybe it is I don't know why
that struck me so much it's not that big
of a deal but I was just watching like
okay what what point was that getting
across Oh his name is Scottie I wrote it
down up index page Scottie
it's Oh Scottie goes down in the cellar
sees what's going on and isn't
responding then the query Scottie and
ash goes down these scares of it's cool
that was kind of suspenseful I liked
that part this movie is super simple um
in a good way it's weird
you see cult classics and you
automatically know why they're called
classics because this is a simple movie
the makeup not great but you still want
to watch the whole thing and it you
understand why it's a cult classic
whereas you see another movie that is
simple and the makeup now great and
you're like that was flippin awful and
terrible so there's some some kind of
distinction um I'm not sure what are
this for this movie here's another
example of that low-budget mnestheus
movie they find The Book of the Dead and
it looks like it's a doodle book for a
goth kid in seventh grade so ash gives
his partner a necklace in a very cute
scene and then you see boobs it's great
then Cheryl the home girl who was
drawing in the beginning and the only
single one there that she's very cute by
the way but Cheryl is a hilarious name
to me I always I want a cat named Cheryl
or like a rats like a pet rat named
Cheryl I think it's the funniest day you
could ever name an animal start going
off in this tangent but anyways Cheryl
here's some more demons and so she goes
out into the woods to investigate alone
Cheryl no and the ancient demons are
speaking English which I love I love
what ancient demons speak English cuz
that's not a thing
then then in the forest she gets wrapped
up in tree branches and she gets fucking
raped by a tree what the hell movie
it doesn't further the plot at all not
even a little bit she everyone else gets
possessed spoilers and none of them had
to get raped by a tree I don't enjoy it
at all and a guy no no guys get raped by
trees and that's a terrible I don't want
that for anyone um but it just needs to
be equal I feel like it just it makes me
so so angry - I feel about tree rape
so it's just like it's not a big deal I
just really don't like it at all I hate
tree right all the time guys I hate tree
rape I hate rape feel very strongly
about that also I'm moving and the
Landlord said that I could do anything I
wanted to the walls are the floors
because they're demolishing the building
the day after I move out so I am nuts
but not that does sad Cheryl makes it
back to the cabin
she's like trees attacked me and they're
like listen nothing's out there and
she's like cool great Cheryl's a demon
now I love it I love I don't love
through it but I love the shells of
Damon so Cheryl is in the cabin and
she's a demon and she takes a pencil and
she stabs the crap out of Ash's
girlfriend and they lock her or like a
bad puppet that doesn't really look like
her in the cellar I love when people get
scared in this movie specifically the
females because they put their hands
through their hair and they yell it's
also filled with terrible acting - so
it's like this isn't something that a
good actor would normally do but I don't
know maybe an excessive ik case I have
no idea it could be good but not in this
movie it is not good what happened to
her
my god what happened to her eyes
so then Scottie tells his hair freak out
girlfriend to go to bed and relax cuz
everything is gonna be okay and then she
immediately gets taken through the
window by a demon and then Scotty's
response to her screams is the worst
acting I've ever perceived in my life he
goes slowly into the bedroom where his
girlfriend was just screaming bloody
murder and then he looks around he sees
that she's not there like super
nonchalant super casual guys this is a
casual situation it's so funny because
it's not a human response to it than
anything that happened
[Music]
is like he was taken by a tree demon I
was able to really look at the window so
didn't help at all but I just looked at
a lot so Shelley's a demon now Shelley
Scotty's girlfriend and Scottie
mutilates her body with an axe while the
demon is gurgling and yelling no you
love her no so they bury Shelley and
Scotty's like we gotta go and ash is
like we can't go Linda's hurt so Scottie
is like well I'm gonna go because we're
going to die and I've hated Scottie up
into this point but I feel that if I was
in that situation I'd be like literally
every horror film is always every time
I'm like why are you there still leave
just go just leave why don't be there
anymore anywhere but the haunted house
that you're in so then Linda turns into
a demon and it's just a mess so ash is
about to dismember Linda but he feels
bad is this his girlfriend so he just
buries her but he knows that's not gonna
work also I feel this is a very
legitimate question why is he taking the
time to bury his friends like this I
know that they're his friends I
understand the sentimental value of it I
just don't understand you're in the
midst of a demon fight and you're taking
valuable time to bury these demons like
when you come back into town and like
all of your friends aren't there are you
gonna be like I don't know I fuck I have
no idea where they are
or you gonna be like they died because
if you tell them that they died or like
that something happened you tell the
truth they're still gonna have to like
go and unburied the bodies like figure
out what happened like it just doesn't
make sense
PSA from Tara chambers don't bury your
friends so he finishes burying Linda and
ten out of ten one hundred percent
guarantee your hand is gonna do that
thing where it pops out of the up there
it is all the demons attack him all of
them except for Shelley because my least
favorite care cook character in the
movie Scotty at least knew to dismember
the demons so the final fight with the
demons happen ash burns the Book of the
Dead then ash just walks away
out of the seemingly unimpressed just
walks out up into the cabin and then he
turns around and you hear /c through
camerawork that a demon like goes inside
of his breath which is a cool setup for
- I feel like everyone says that - is
way better though which I'm excited
about because I understand why one is a
cult classic I enjoyed it I laughed I
think I know way more than I was scared
I definitely wasn't scared by this movie
but I appreciated the suspense and I
appreciated what they did with such a
small budget there was a lot of problems
with it but I still enjoyed it it was it
was bad but in great I'll see you guys
next week with Evil Dead 2 -
did you like Evil Dead were you scared
do you like me you do huh you do like me
that's why we're best friends